hello who the heck are you and what do
you do I
my name is license and I
a professional choreographer dancer how
where and why did you get the idea to do
a video with my mom Perry
my mom takes line dancing classes and
she's always asked me if I could come
and teach her class
yeah so I ended up teaching my mom some
steps just to test how good she was and
then I started realizing that she has a
crazy learning ability so once I
realized she could run really fast I
started teaching her
and then I realized that I had to film a
video so think oh my gosh skills are
crazy and I was just like testing Roos
out on there
like she had done my dancing 15 years
but before that yeah it's almost like
today would you say oh for sure she's a
natural she's definitely a crazy crazy
national she has no experience with any
other styles and line dancing how much
you said it before but it's just it's
like a lot of just step touches and just
like simple foot works but yeah she's
like picking up crazy arm and she could
see stuff like flies like something yeah
totally I didn't go to teacher class I
was kind of skeptical of teaching her
thoughts cuz I didn't want to teach too
difficult of stuff to advise and so when
I talked I taught her as like a test and
I was testing it moves on there like
it's all that she does really fast and
I'll just crack it up and then that's
when I was like okay and so I was just
testing out like what looks funny on her
and then I was like okay we're gonna
record a video and I was just doing like
things I thought would look funniest on
a mom yeah and that's how that routine
care about
not too but like it also seems so
appropriate because that's like my mom
already that song too it's a song that
my mom actually know it's gonna be yeah
I'm Korean so she already knew about it
before it blew up
yeah in the early stages so I was like
my mom knows the song already it only
makes sense but the whole time she was
just like super train taking seriously
that was just like giving Airy some
basic stuff and I was like no just do it
help me want to do it even you just
trying it's cute you know just like no
and she was like trying to get perfect I
was like whoa
definitely he was not expecting like
respond setting try I do like thinking
that I knew like I'm doing a video my
mom would like probably funny to watch
but I didn't think yeah Forest what was
it like before being on The Ellen Show
everyone was cool Ellen is awesome she
was really nice that whole staff that
was really nice too
who experienced a whole family all
together yeah I saw you uh you block you
I couldn't blog yeah I think your mom -
you - yeah did she follow you together
she watches lion dancing clips on
YouTube so she's actually on YouTube
regularly just looking at line dancing
clips
not really not she doesn't do any of
that she just such as line dancing of
clips and watches that oh yeah she
watches my stuff like all day long -
sheesh everybody yeah she like totally
like her friends are like watching my
videos and stuff too and like sometimes
like sometimes like all I catch her like
just like watching my videos
Ellen is also constantly playing up new
EDRs
you think this is helping to legitimize
what about legitimizing but I definitely
feel like it's just emerging it's just
making it seem so accessible this is
such a grand scale audience in a way
that not a lot of shows do so in that
way I think she's just kind of bridging
the gap they contacted me really early
actually before it really blew up it was
probably out like 50,000 views like the
first day like first half day I already
all my email booking email accounts my
facebook all were I received a message
from the social producer kind of just
like already being like we're interested
I was like before I even saw going to do
that if you say guarantee before YouTube
even became what it is
yeah what are the differences between
dancing
like affordances
oh that's a good question
they're both double-edged swords they're
both pros the cons to both the first pro
that comes to mind for YouTube is the
fact that it's you have 100% credit
control like whatever you want to do you
can just do it and put it out but the
difference is also can also hide things
too whereas like live performance and
whatnot YouTube doesn't quite capture a
performance quality kind of takes out an
aspect though you can make a cool video
without being a great performance so can
always expect a great performer because
I don't feel like that's something
that's different back in the back in the
day I think there was a lot of awesome
performers so when you watch them on
stage you would like just see that
they're better than performing but now
like so many people are so focused on
making videos they're not cultivating
their performance
YouTube like as it's like small
sometimes I'm sorry cat videos videos do
you think that has a
I'm definitely still learning I'm
learning a lot right now - about like
how to create memes for YouTube kind of
learning that for instance like eg buddy
it's kind of a TV so like can can't let
things like anger on too long and I'm
just kind of focus I guess I'm studying
other YouTube videos right now before I
was just thinking about like dancer
audience but now I'm kind of studying a
lot of others niche world per se like
whether it's like the gaming world or
even like beauty guru world and YouTube
and it's kind of studying how they make
their videos so I think that I don't can
still has such a big beyond its
mainstream breaking through through some
television shows it's still such a tiny
bubble
my first motivation in my crate buses is
always music always I find a song like
that instead of like pre-ground the
story that I want to do I'll listen to
the song and then I just kind of imagine
like I'm like a movie soundtrack yeah
it's kind of like things like what is
this songs feel like picture wise then I
see what it looks like then I'm okay
then I'll start choreographing like
there's like a section of the music kind
of figure out how their photograph I'll
start choreographing a bigger part the
music and then just pick a location I
matching the story but yeah it all roots
back to the music the music kind of
tells I feel like the music is just like
is the guy like okay should be this then
there should be this and I'm just
reading the music
into a tangible form would you ever
branch out to do I guess it more web
series of invested areas or stories or
boys
to each other yeah I'm part of the Greek
club hinges and we are basically a dance
anime and we are doing a basically
webisode series of dance concert videos
that's building upon stories about
grouping for other ninjas but you're
twined with dance as well and I have
another episode storyline called MSG
just like my own character linoleum yes
missus this is miss linoleum
but yeah it's like just stringing along
some really into anime and comics
fantasy in general so I just like mixing
the two worlds so it's like creating
little stories to go along with the
dancing obviously yeah do you see
yourself doing
I think film it's the main thing my
biggest passion is entertainment like I
feel like dance is the weapon that I
just fell into or not weapon but I would
say like style it feels like martial
arts and someone's just interested in
fighting they just grew up in like the
Shaolin monk school and this is just the
school that I fell in to dance but in
general entertainment is like my biggest
passion so I know that gravity takes the
direction
what is it that you're trying to tell
people that isn't this
the story the message I'll leave your
market yeah I guess my biggest thing is
the concept of passing on positive
energy and what I mean by that is like
power of like encouragement encouraging
people because I feel like for me the
biggest moments that changed my life
where when people gave me encouragement
and I feel like there's so much judgment
I mean that's natural everybody's kind
of mindset we're all human but it's like
the same time we should bounce that out
with encouragement as well because the
more you pass along with that it's
contagious you know so I think that
paired with I love being able to take
anybody away I'm a fan of anything that
takes me out of the real world and when
I watch fantasies that decide just makes
me so happy and inspired to just think
beyond this world so I love anything of
that realm so to mix that but the
concept of positivity along with just
out of this world make you feel like
it's it again that's like
pretty much yes very like positive
they said earlier YouTube is much like
everyone has a scale over them where
they can
to conference yeah like you'd like
negative comments or like just like
videos especially when like you're
trying to say like okay I'm trying to
make something for you that's yeah yeah
hey I just kind of I'm assuming that I
mean I could be wrong it's easy to just
be like a like a bad kid and just write
whatever you want on anything you know
say you're just like no this sucks and
you just say what your mind so dang it
is yeah you know it's just kind of like
everyone has their own opinion you know
and like they're not realizing I know a
lot of times they're not trying to be
like I want you to die like there's not
necessarily directing that energy at me
I'm just kind of accepting like we're
just saying their opinion they're not
like face to face with me like trying to
put it at me they're just saying what's
on their mind and that's cool and as
long as there are some people that are
feeling it that's what helps me balance
it out cuz I mean I think if it was all
you suck quit now
you still quit now I'd probably like hey
this is her she's not feeling good but I
think the balance of the positive
feedback that I get back just whenever I
see negative comment I'm just like this
is a little angry because I'll let them
be angry at something
working on dance showdown season two of
down showdown that's actually gonna air
pretty soon teacher mentor and also
performing with them too like we perform
a duet with all our old all them it's
like a dance
YouTube version of Dancing with the
Stars where it's dance experts are
paired with YouTube celebrities to you
know teach him a dance and then we
perform and we're judged on that and
there's you votes voting system and the
winner gets $100,000
so I don't know any but anybody who's
watching this vote for us yes way
souped-up from season one if you ever
watch season one a dance showdown that
was cool that's easy too is like all new
setup everything is just bigger and
better so I have out of the many I have
one big game one of my
leadership like to calm canticles and
even though there are musicals right now
that exist quit dancing my idea is kind
of that it's a to show that's headlined
by dancing as opposed to dancing just
being the we bonus cherry on top
it's headlined by dancing but the
stories are intertwined but it's a
really high level of dancing
particularly street styles which are
incorporated with each other
mantasy involved I mean this there's
several things that exist there's also
like like a dream would be I know that
there's a Batman show that exists right
now at the live-action Batman show and I
would love for that to have something
with like a street dance appropriate
because the director of the Batman shows
into haven't even last I would cuz I'm
on a project called blaze which is also
it's a show headlined by street dancing
but that's in Europe and in Europe these
shows headlined by with dancing it's
just a lot it's just in the u.s. that
it's really rare for there to be a show
headlined by the mob dance I think the
only show that exists like guys the
Jabbawockeez show but besides that
there's no other show so I think it's
time for many other shows to come in
because it's totally something that
yeah toriel is there already posted
online right now on my second channel
yeah just teach basic tutorials because
I've been getting the requests for like
years in my comments I was always
hesitant on tutorials because I always
had this image in my head that it would
look like a fitness DVD for some reason
I was like I don't want to look ok ok
yeah I want to be like oh God
but ya know I kind of realized that I
learned off of instructionals myself and
once I realized like there are actually
people that want to learn all I need to
do is to put something out and these
people can actually benefit from that